foreign
[Music]
I know it's stupid to talk about games
about some good good CS stories this
weekend oh man oh man hit me all right
first of all as I've been ranking up the
learning curve has been [__] crazy
like there's a there's a level of play
you know the the graph kind of went like
this it's like a you know like a bell
yeah so like the you know the it was
incremental and then I ranked up
recently and now it just jumped like
three levels what jumped the stand the
standard of game
oh so you're like way better you're
saying no I mean like the teammates oh I
see so in the ranks I was in previously
I would hang around the top right
[Laughter]
just gotta love just gotta put that out
there yeah okay you know just you know
little games you know a little little 26
and seven KD you know but now the ranks
I'm in I'm barely hanging on
like so these dudes are good I was like
scared
like a grown man and I'm scared
first of all the comms way different
really at the lower ranks you you you're
like hey what's up team and they're like
What's Up [__] yeah
at this level
it's like yo yo
um yeah I've played with that guy before
uh he tends to he's an opera he likes to
hang out at B I say we try a cool cool
I'm gonna buy smoke yeah do you know the
CT flash yeah I'm gonna do and you're
like
here's in there and they talk to me and
they're like Yo dude buy smoke okay you
have to cover stairs okay no I'm like
I'm just honest I go sorry boys I don't
know that at all
and they go all right and they go
yeah for [__] sake okay
they're like all right cool why don't
you try to entry frag
it's so you know they're just like
relegate me to the to the dumb ass cool
we'll do that and what is that again
they lightly condescend okay I see they
go that's okay all right why don't you
hang out and uh we'll set everything up
and then you can run out and talk to me
like I'm a child
just explore the controls yeah and kind
of let's just give you this one yeah
we'll give you this area just focus on
getting a kill yeah yeah let's let's do
that yeah let's focus on not dying yeah
oh dude they get so mad when you don't
trade okay like what they want is if
they die you better be there to trade
the other guy out so they don't care if
they die but if they die and you sat
there hiding because you were scared and
you didn't peek to try to make it an
even trade I didn't do it one round this
guy [__] he goes dude can you [__]
peek I'm like yes
cool and what are you
I'm a little peaky boy sir
that's right I want to hear those
push-ups doing push-ups in front of my
computer
hacker on the mic you just hear
it's counting on the other side 45 46
47.
you better not quit on me [__]
that's right
so I had one guy I was like crying
laughing inside the whole time because
he took everything very literally
and he was really upset the whole time
okay so
he might like call a strat and people
don't really listen he starts talking to
himself on the mic he's like oh okay all
right so we're just doing whatever we
want this game
it's like a character you would do but
it's like he's serious that's awesome so
he's kind of starts being a dick and I'm
trying to be nice to him then he gets
into this kind of Rich dick attitude
where he's like well I mean we boys we
have to save our money otherwise what
are we doing here and I'd be like yeah
what are we doing here man just egging
him on okay
so then we had a round where we didn't
listen to him
and he's like oh okay all right so we're
just what the what are we doing guys
what are we doing and I go we're playing
for picks which means you're just like
slow playing it you're trying to get
someone he goes oh right right right
we're playing for picks okay yeah sure
okay all right
and I'm like this guy's being an [__]
so then we're getting towards the end of
the game and it's like kind of on its
Edge
and he keeps talking [__] and I can tell
the two guys that are playing with me
we're kind of split like three of us are
playing one side of the map to him and
another guy playing the other side he's
hyping himself up the whole time I think
his ego was getting hurt because he
would kill a lot of people and no one
would say anything yes
so he'd be like I mean come on I'm
rolling these guys am I not
silence he's getting upset as the game
is taken by
so much so that when we would lose on
our side of the map he'd be like I guess
you guys can't hold it can you they're
not they're not afraid to you know
they're afraid to come over here they're
very confident going over there I'm like
I guess they are man
he's getting really amped so then we're
at a pretty crucial round and I did
something that basically
guaranteed we would lose okay what'd you
do so
three of us the three that he was
nagging I friendly fired my entire team
no no
oh
so he was being so annoying that uh uh
someone did do that okay yeah someone
killed him yeah killed him because he
wouldn't shut the [__] up okay and he
went [__] parabolic and then we win
the round so that kind of tempered him
okay which I thought was like kind of
interesting yeah yeah we get a gun we
get an AK from the other team
and now he goes well I'm broke because
your team killed me so you better give
me that gun so it's like he's on the
limit okay and then the guy who got the
AK he throws it on the ground at the
start of the round and it's near me okay
and I have money
so I buy a rifle I give it to one of my
guys and I take the AK okay so this
leaves this guy with no rifle and he's
like oh oh so after all the [__]
kills I get you're just gonna take the
[__] gun from me in there and now
he's ran like he is random 45 seconds
straight chewing us out
bad attitude so angry and it's like
hysterical I'm like this guy is so upset
we win the round
I give him that gun the next round okay
he doesn't know what to do
I took it from one week he's like well
thank you couldn't even Muster that okay
he's so angry yeah and then uh then my
guys on my side of the map didn't really
care so we lose our side of the map and
he's like oh I guess the guys on our
side have to fix it he's talking himself
up with him and this other guy you know
we've been killing all games gotta be us
now and then they die and they lose the
game like they lose the round that loses
the game and I just to insult the injury
I get on the mic and I go oh I guess you
don't have it he's like you're bad you
should kill yourself oh dude really to
the roof and then he quits the game no
way yeah me and the other guys are just
laughing hard man what was crazy was one
of the guys was talking
in there and he's talking about playing
again like it was a drug okay he goes
yeah I took about a 10-year Hiatus from
this but I'm back on everyone's like
hell yeah welcome back oh no you know
what he said what he goes yeah well I
just logged like 6 500 hours in the last
two years
so I wanted to break that down 6 500
hours over two years so divide that by
What's 365 times two
I think 43 yeah
8.9 hours a day every day for two years
yeah and so what's crazy about that is
insane it is that restrictive because
you not you know the exact time frame
and it also means like
he had to have left his place at some
point to like do errands and stuff like
that which means other days he's
accounting for
the the hours that he missed so it could
because a lot of the days he's playing
12 13 hours
he probably has a job
maybe does he I mean how else would you
do that how would you survive how could
you play this much with a job 60 hours
of gaming a week bro yeah
that's [__] crazy I I've just
forgotten about this genre of human yeah
and it's just uh it's always eye-opening
yeah the the numbers that these guys
throw out when they're like yeah I
logged 5 000 hours last year